show me anybody that's maniacal anybody
thats obsess anybody that's doing
something at a very very high level I
will show you somebody that worked at
some point in their lives with someone
that had very high standards and
expectations of them here's why it could
have been military it could have been a
father a mother a teacher or coach
somebody had such high standards of
themselves at that point that this
person felt like man I can never do
anything in this person's eyes but what
they don't realize is those standards
they stick they stay with them for a
while and then whatever else they do in
their lives it's like man I don't feel
like I'm there yet I don't feel like I'm
good I don't feel like I'm there yet in
that mindset eventually in any industry
they're part of takes them straight to
the top in this video I'll be talking
about two different things one is seven
reasons why companies leaders and
organizations lower their standards and
the other thing I'll be talking about is
five things you ought to be thinking
about before raising your standards
within your organization this morning I
was having my weekly conference call
with the executives and the topic came
up about success and how we can take our
game to whole different level and I was
speaking to one of the leaders and I
said one of the things we can learn a
lot about ourselves is when we succeed
what do you mean well when someone
succeed there's two reactions let me
explain to what happens one of the
reactions is oh my gosh I just made 200
grand last month they're going
cruise-control the other reaction of
somebody who's 60s they say wait a
minute I just did XYZ and I made
$200,000 what if I do XYZ and ABC I
could make a million dollars in a month
are you kidding me boom I'm going after
this right after they become full their
stomach is full they're winning they're
making more money so going to country
club special parties special invitations
nicer house nicer car nicer girl nicer
guy nicer everything changes upgrade
everybody dresses you personal tailor
you know oh my gosh my watch guy my
clothes I car guy my this guy and you
all of a sudden become a phenomenon and
that hunger goes away so many companies
when they go through massive success all
of a sudden standards lowers so again
the number one reason why leaders come
and corporations lower their standards
this typically happens following a
massive victory a win or success so
after you achieve success a lot of temps
people stop working that hard they come
in at 11 o'clock instead of 7 o'clock in
the morning and do cardio they stop
taking care their diet they kind of
start eating out too much they put on 30
40 50 pounds they work less they're no
longer coming to work working very hard
so what happens when you the leader
doesn't work very hard psychologically
you don't expect as much effort from
everybody because you're not putting
everything in and this leads me to
number three when you don't give
everything to everybody in your brain
you become very paranoid thinking this
person is about to leave you that person
is about to quit this person is about to
take off this person is going to go to a
competitor so rather than leading your
organization which is what people want
they want to be led you become someone
that is solving for being liked by
everybody so you become a people pleaser
and there isn't any leader I know that's
built an organization on high standards
that maintains it while wanting to
please everybody in the organization
those two just don't go together so this
leads to many organizations when they
fear losing people they just start
giving titles away hey you are now the
vice-president hey you are now the chief
such-and-such officer and they create
whatever type of a position hey you are
now being promoted to such-and-such
let's give everybody the titles because
people really want titles by the way big
thinkers are not driven by titles big
thinkers are driven by doing big things
so this retains people who are driven by
titles but this same method that we just
talked about loses the people that are
big thinkers that are driven by doing
something that's never been done before
this formula actually becomes absolutely
a disaster for any company that follows
this so when companies start giving away
promotions and titles to people who
didn't earn it
this is what happens those who did earn
it and they've been around start
resenting the leadership person that
gave the promotion to another person
that didn't sacrifice as much as they
did so what happens there yes you may
lose a few people but what's even worse
than that the team is no longer on the
same page and if the teams no longer on
the same page you are not going in one
direction think about it this way you
you are attacking you're playing
football there's a magnet team you got a
team football you everybody's supposed
to go on the other side to score
touchdown one guy's running this way one
guy's running this way one guy's running
this way one guy's running this way
you're not going to score any touchdowns
right there is no play like that
everybody has to move this way if your
team is no longer on the same page and
it's scattered forget about growth
momentum is absolutely gone by the way
here's one thing to be thinking about
that could contradict my first five
points many people you may have know
could have been high standards for
three-year period or a five-year period
or a seven-year period and you're
wondering wait a minute
that person used to be high standards
but they dropped why did they lowered
their standards because their vision
wasn't big it was a small vision so for
a small vision you only need high
standards for a couple years you don't
need it forever so a lot of times
standards get dropped because the vision
was also very small so when the vision
is small and the leaders dreams become a
reality all of us um what happens is the
leader loses fire the hearts no longer
in the game and you notice this within
their eyes and then you notices in the
language they speak and the effort they
put in the office you no longer see them
and they keep telling me I'm running
conference calls I'm working hard I'm
running this I'm traveling and they want
to make sure everybody knows they're
busy but in reality they're not busy
their hearts no longer in the business
they're not even connected they become
disconnected it's almost like you know
the whole thing in relationship when
somebody says I used to love you but I
don't think I'm in love with you anymore
they're no longer in love and other
people pay the price for this person's
heart no longer being in a business so
the company you saw this happening with
Sears here's a company that's been
around for 125 plus years they go from
dominating everybody right world war one
they made it World War two they made a
Great Depression they made her no
problems they cannot compete against
Amazon or Target or some of these other
companies and now they have to pay a
debt payment yesterday 134 million
dollars filing bankruptcy chapter 11
closing up another 124 different stores
what happened there the leader lost
heart and sometimes when you hire the
person that doesn't have heart or you
hire somebody that doesn't have the
vision next thing you know everybody
else pays a price for it so you may be
watching the same pad I don't want to
see this happen to my company I love the
people I work with I love the PIO even
love the guy at the top I love to see
you I love the visionary but
maybe he's lost so what do we do about
this first of all everybody's got to
watch this video here together
and ask like this is you got to be
transparent with yourself it's gonna
hurt a little bit
you gotta identify some of your blind
spots then once you go through the first
seven issues we talked about and here's
five things to think about on raising
your standards so the first thing you
need to do is you need to define what
high standards is a lot of times I go to
offices or businesses I'll sit down with
the CEO and they'll say we run a very
high standard type of a business our
people are expected to da da da da and I
saw it's great give me an example of
what high standards means to you well
you know we expect our guys to be driven
by excellence okay the general statement
I'm talking specific give me some
specific data what you need to well you
know we expect our people to work very
hard
again another general statement this
doesn't work high standards needs to be
defined very specific so what is the
definition of high standards high
standards to me is somebody who does 38
this 120 this shows up at this time goes
out at this time makes this many calls
runs this many appointments define it
specific to the T so number one define
and set high standards number two once
you define and you set high standards
then you got to communicate it to
everybody on what high standards are
these are our standards are moving
forward in this department in this
department in this department would this
person with that person so you
communicate it to everybody the third
thing you got to do as a leader after
you define high standards after you go
out then you know communicate the high
standards then you got a cell why I need
to buy you into high standards I'm
sitting there saying come on man you
want me to buy high centers yes why sell
it to me they're not saying it to you
but they're thinking that sell me why I
need to buy into the idea of your high
standards tell me why I need to believe
that you are gonna yourself perform
based on high standards then I'm sinners
to my kind of like what he's talking
about what do you mean by selling high
standards this organization won because
of high standards this leader did this
because he had high standards this
country did this because of high
standards this sports team won because
of high standards this team came
together and they did this because they
committed to high standards and look
where they are now you need to sell me a
found
on you sell me on why I need to buy into
your high standards if you've done all
of those things now you got to drive
high standards over and over and over
and over again you become a master
reminder of high standards reminder of
high standards why you want people to
recommit to high standards re-energized
on what high standards with consistency
with Johnny with Bobby with Larry with
Mary with everybody high standards high
it could be the front desk clerk that
all she does is answers the phones but
you got to say look when I answer the
phone yes or no I want you to be smiling
I want you to how many help you how you
doing I want you to have some energy
when you go to the person in the back
that's leading their team I want you to
be excited I want you to come to work
and fire me up with your team up three
different people that work with you and
then with your person has to see oh hey
I know you got 200 people reporting to
my man I want you to get them excited
high standards with consistency amongst
everybody number 5 is if somebody says
oh I know you're just talking about this
let you have a certain set of rules or
principles or guidelines or values that
you want to run with every once in a
while everybody needs to know how
serious you are so what does that mean
whether you need to let go of somebody
asked him to leave fired them any of
that stuff
every once in a while every once in a
while you need to do this it isn't easy
it's gonna confuse some people some
people are gonna get scared some people
can say oh my gosh but here's what
happens everyone realizes you're not
playing so here's two things I want you
to do number one I want you to send me a
tweet that Patrick made they were right
down here and tell me exactly who is
that one person in your life who had
high standards and expectations of you
once you do that the next video I want
you to watch it's a video I did maybe a
year and a half ago titled twenty-one
differences between managers and leaders
take you everybody